hey guys let's talk about blackheads
how do you get them and how do you get
rid of them well that's what we're going
to talk about
in this video let's get to it
i have a dream
[Music]
just very quick if it's the first time
that you're here on my channel welcome
my name is daniel
if you haven't subscribed yet please
consider it and also click that
notification bell
so you won't miss any of the next videos
here we talk about fitness grooming
style and life itself everything has got
to do
with men now let's talk about those
blackheads
first you need to understand that they
are a form of acne they are basically
dirt oil excess skin cells that clog
your pores
they have open surfaces and they turn
black when they
are exposed to air oxidation so here's
seven tips
that i'm gonna give you to get rid of
them
[Music]
don't use blackhead strips it's just a
money-making thing
and if you start to use them you're
always just going to use them because
your blackheads will just always keep
coming back and not only that they
always only remove
the top of the blackhead and not the
root of it
[Music]
don't use a normal bar of soap don't
wash your face with it why
because they leave residue and they are
contributing to your blackheads because
they clog
your pores
don't use harsh blackhead treatments
there are things like abrasive scrubs
and things like
skin aggravating ingredients that's just
going to make it worse
so don't use things with sd alcohol
peppermint or menthol so try to stay
away from everything that's
aggravating and irritating your skin
because that just might
contribute to more blackheads why
because your skin is going to produce
more oil and if you get more oil
you're going to get more blackheads
people with oily skin struggle a lot
more with blackheads
[Music]
you got to use the right face wash and
you got to do it
two times a day or in some cases three
times a day depending on when you work
out because
you gotta wash your face again after you
had your workout
and then when you wash your skin do it
gently i'll add some good product
options for you in the video description
down below
that you can check out but try to get a
good face wash with
salicylic acid in it
now what you can also do is use a levon
acelic acid
now if you're new to this this is
basically an exfoliant a bha
exfoliant bha stands for beta hydroxy
acid
this works great because they penetrate
the skin deep enough
to unplug pores deep into their roots
and that's exactly what you want i know
paula's choice
they got a good product called clear but
i'll also add some other options for you
in the video description
down below
[Music]
[Applause]
you gotta control your oily face there
are good products out there that you can
use
to help you with your oily face i
personally like polo's choice and also
geology
the reason i'm mentioning these products
is because if you use the right skincare
products
the right routine it will automatically
help you with all your skincare
conditions and that
includes your blackheads with geology
they create
a unique skincare set for you that will
work specifically
for your skin's condition
[Music]
use a blackhead extractor if you've got
very stubborn
blackheads then you can use this
extractor instead
of squeezing scratching and pinching
your blackheads
that'll just make it worse now if you
want more skincare tips
watch one of these videos here and i'll
see you there cheers guys